[MUSIC PLAYING]
[MARY KATE MOORE SINGING "I
DREAMED A DREAM"]
[APPLAUSE]
[NICK CARTELL SINGING "BRING HIM
HOME"]
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: First of all, wow.
[LAUGHTER]
Thank you for those
incredible performances
and for being with
us here today.
We're so, so excited to
have you, so thank you.
NICK CARTELL: We're
excited to be here.
So thank you so
much for having us.
SPEAKER 1: So to
get things started,
I thought we could just do
a few rapid fire questions
if you can just answer
with the first thing that
comes to your mind.
So, Kate, if you want to
go first and then Nick.
NICK CARTELL: Great.
MARY KATE MOORE: OK.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
First one, favorite
song in "Les Mis."
MARY KATE MOORE: "One Day More."
NICK CARTELL: "Bring Him Home."
[LAUGHTER]
MARY KATE MOORE: [INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER 1: Favorite
song you don't sing.
NICK CARTELL: Oh.
MARY KATE MOORE: Uh-oh.
He doesn't like any
of the other ones.
NICK CARTELL: "The People's
Song," "The People's Song."
SPEAKER 1: OK, perfect.
MARY KATE MOORE: OK.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
Last thing you googled?
MARY KATE MOORE: The
full moon lunar eclipse
that's happening today.
SPEAKER 1: Oh.
MARY KATE MOORE: Yeah.
NICK CARTELL: How to
properly tie a Windsor knot.
[LAUGHTER]
MARY KATE MOORE: It looks good.
NICK CARTELL: I
think I did it right.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
MARY KATE MOORE:
Yeah, you did it.
SPEAKER 1: Looks great.
MARY KATE MOORE:
You totally did it.
SPEAKER 1: Favorite
city you have performed
in not including Denver?
MARY KATE MOORE: Seattle.
NICK CARTELL: Nashville.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
And last one-- dream
role in any musical?
MARY KATE MOORE: I'm
going to say Mother
in "Ragtime" in 20 years.
NICK CARTELL: Phantom in
"The Phantom of the Opera."
SPEAKER 1: Oh.
[LAUGHTER]
MARY KATE MOORE:
They know that one.
NICK CARTELL: Why, thank you.
SPEAKER 1: Perfect.
OK.
So now we'll get into some
more in-depth questions.
So if you can both tell
us a little bit more
about how you got
involved with "Les Mis"
and what the audition
process was like?
MARY KATE MOORE: Sure.
Well, I first auditioned
for this show in, I think,
April of 2016 and did
not originally get cast
and waited for maybe
three or four months.
And it was kind of
down to the wire
for the casting team I think.
They were about to start
rehearsals in a couple weeks.
So I went back in
for another audition
that I didn't realize was
kind of a final callback.
And I started my
journey with "Les Mis"
as a member of the female
ensemble understudying Fantine.
And in March of this year,
I bumped up and started
playing the role full-time.
SPEAKER 1: Amazing.
MARY KATE MOORE: Yeah.
NICK CARTELL: And I started--
my initial audition
was in April.
And I actually, I think,
was one of the last people
that was cast and over the
course of five callbacks,
and then finally
booked the role.
MARY KATE MOORE: Booked it.
NICK CARTELL: So here we are.
SPEAKER 1: Yes.
Well, congrats to you both.
NICK CARTELL: Yeah, thanks.
SPEAKER 1: I saw
it on Wednesday.
You're both amazing in the show.
MARY KATE MOORE: Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: Nick, can you tell
us a little bit more what
it's like to play such an
iconic role of Jean Valjean?
And are there any
actors who have
played the role in the past
that inspired your performance?
NICK CARTELL: Sure.
It's very easy.
No.
[LAUGHTER]
It is very demanding.
But it also-- because there's
a lot of responsibility
that comes with
playing this character.
So many people have--
you know, amazing men
who have come before me
that have played this role--
Colm Wilkinson, you know,
Hugh Jackman in the movie.
You've got, you know, all
of these amazing artists.
And you also have
a responsibility
to the fans of "Les Miserables"
that have seen the show that
know what this character is.
And so it also is fun to
kind of make it your own.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
NICK CARTELL: And you
have to make it your own.
And I feel like I have
made it my own, you know?
But I would say
some of the people
that I look up to,
obviously, is Colm.
I mean, he started
the whole thing.
You have to look up to the
man who originated the role.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
NICK CARTELL: But then, also, I
did a regional production of it
about nine years ago.
And so the two gentlemen that
played Valjean when I actually
played Marius really
I looked up to,
because I saw how
they made it their own
and how they sing differently
and stuff like that.
So it was a good
prep, yeah, for this.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
That's great.
Kate, Fantine
makes a huge impact
in the beginning of the show.
How do you prepare each night
to start off the show so strong?
Do you have any special
rituals or things
you do before each night?
MARY KATE MOORE:
I think its kind
of absorbing the energy
of the rest of the cast.
Because it is true that I am
introduced and then, like,
about 30 minutes later, I'm
dying in a hospital bed.
So--
[LAUGHTER]
--that's over very quickly.
NICK CARTELL: Spoiler alert.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
MARY KATE MOORE: Oh, sorry
if you haven't seen it.
Spoiler alert, I die.
[LAUGHTER]
But I wouldn't say that
I'm the only person making
a high impact at
the top of the show.
There's really no such
thing as easing gently
into a performance of "Les Mis."
SPEAKER 1: Yes, right.
MARY KATE MOORE: So I think
it's just meeting my fellow cast
mates where they are
when they start the show.
Because we all kind of
have to give 100%, so.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, cool.
And this is can be
for both of you,
if you both want
to answer just one.
So the show has so,
so much history.
It not only takes place
in 19th century France,
but it's also based on Victor
Hugo's 1,500 page novel
from 1862.
And that is a lot of content.
How have you gone about
preparing for your roles?
And is there any extra research
you did before you started?
NICK CARTELL: I
did read the book.
SPEAKER 1: Oh, wow.
NICK CARTELL: It took me
months, but I did read the book.
Because, I mean, that's
a natural resource.
You have the original words
that Victor Hugo wrote
that are right there that can
tell you everything you need
to know about the characters.
And, you know, yes,
you can take stuff.
But there's one line in the
book that Javert actually
says to Valjean.
The way that he recognized
Jean Valjean at one point
is because he walks with a limp.
And it was literally just
one line that is written.
And so I adapted that
into my character.
So as I age through
the show, when
we get into it, when
I'm in older age,
I start walking with a limp.
And it was literally
stuff like that
that I was able to
take out of the book
and put into my character.
And also, just to see
the way that, you know,
Valjean is so broken
at the beginning
and how everybody
treats him really
helps to inform my character
and journey every night.
So, for me, that was
truly what I did.
MARY KATE MOORE: What he said.
I don't have a limp, though.
SPEAKER 1: Did you
also read the book?
MARY KATE MOORE: Yes, I did.
SPEAKER 1: Oh, wow.
That's amazing.
MARY KATE MOORE: I was first
introduced to it when I
was a sophomore in high school.
And I didn't know the
musical at that point.
And we watched the very famous
10th anniversary production
concert version of it in
bits and pieces in class.
So, yeah, that was when
the love affair started.
NICK CARTELL: And when
we started rehearsal
the first day, we all walked
in with the novel sitting
at our binders.
SPEAKER 1: Oh, wow.
NICK CARTELL: So they
gave us the novel.
And they were like, get ready.
[LAUGHTER]
Here you go.
SPEAKER 1: Some light reading.
NICK CARTELL: Welcome.
MARY KATE MOORE: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: So then
do either of you
remember the first
time you saw the show?
NICK CARTELL: [INAUDIBLE]
MARY KATE MOORE: I saw it--
I think it was 2014 in London.
I saw it on the West End.
SPEAKER 1: Oh, wow.
MARY KATE MOORE: That's the only
other professional production
that I've seen or been involved
with at all before this one,
so.
SPEAKER 1: Oh, wow.
MARY KATE MOORE: Yeah.
NICK CARTELL: And I saw it
in the tour version in 1996--
5-- when it played my
hometown in Tempe, Arizona.
So that was really, really
great that I got to see it there
and sat in the top balcony
and was just amazed.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
So "Les Mis" first
premiered in Paris
in 1980 almost 40 years ago.
And it's still a
worldwide success.
Why do you think the show has
really stood the test of time?
MARY KATE MOORE: I think
that, even though it
takes such a long
time ago, there
are a lot of very important
and pertinent issues
that the show deals
with that's happening
for us societally right now.
There's a lot of members
of the cast a lot
of characters that are
ostracize persons and oppressed.
And there's a lot of that
going on in the world
that we experience every day.
So I think audience
members either find
it really relatable, or they
experience a really important
lesson over and
over and over again
of looking out for people who
are more vulnerable than you.
And so it's important
for both of us,
I think, to be able to tell
the stories of these characters
that do experience
that oppression,
because it is so important now.
I don't know if you have
anything to add to that.
NICK CARTELL: Yeah,
no, I would say that,
and then the music is
what brings people back.
I mean, these are
songs that you know.
They've been on the radio.
I mean, it's pop
culture at this point.
So I think that people
come back to see the show,
because they have
love for the show
along with connecting with
these characters that are just
a fight for the human
spirit, trying to make
the world a better place.
SPEAKER 1: So when
did both of you
get first involved with theater?
And was there anyone that
inspired you to start acting?
MARY KATE MOORE: You.
You took the breath first.
NICK CARTELL: I first
got involved with theater
when I was in fifth grade.
I had always grown up
singing in choirs and things
like that-- seventh
grade, sorry.
And I ended up
doing a production
of an opera called "Amahl
and the Night Visitors"
around Christmas.
And that was kind
of what sparked it.
And then I went and saw a
field trip of a production
of "Cinderella."
And I was like, that's
what I want to do.
They're doing what I love.
And then it just kind
of took off from there.
And ever since then, that's
what I've been doing.
MARY KATE MOORE: I
was a late bloomer.
I didn't really do musical
theater until high school,
actually.
My first show was
when I was a freshman.
I did "Hello, Dolly!"
I was in the ensemble.
I had a lot of straw hats.
[LAUGHTER]
But it was great.
Yeah.
And I remember, like,
waiting in the wings
before the show started one
night with our, like, now I
know very sub-par high school
orchestra playing the overture.
And just experiencing the
feeling of anticipation
before going on
stage, I was like,
oh my god, people
do this as a career.
I want to do this.
So, yeah, that's it.
SPEAKER 1: Very cool.
And both of you have been
in lots of other shows.
What's it like to be in "Les
Mis" versus, like, past shows
that you've been in?
NICK CARTELL: It's huge.
This show is huge.
And because you are meeting
fans at the stage door
that have either seen
it before or it's
their first time
seeing it, and so
you have a
responsibility to them.
But then you also have
responsibility to the work.
But then you also just
get to do "Les Mis."
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
NICK CARTELL: I mean, it's been
running for almost 40 years.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
NICK CARTELL: I
mean, and so to say,
I'm in "Les Miserables"
is pretty cool, you know?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
NICK CARTELL: We all have-- some
of us in the company have swag,
you know.
So we'll have a
jacket or a hat on.
And we'll walk in, and they'll
be, like, are you in the show?
We're, like, yeah,
just a little bit.
You know, so I mean, it's fun.
MARY KATE MOORE:
Just a little bit.
NICK CARTELL: It's
exciting for us.
MARY KATE MOORE: Just
most of the show.
NICK CARTELL: I'm
like five minutes.
That's it.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
Switching gears a
little bit, what
is the best advice either
of you have been given?
MARY KATE MOORE: So I would say
probably just to release any
expectations you have
about where you need to be
and to just do
your job, you know,
with integrity whether that's--
for us performers,
you know, it's
sometimes difficult
to find work.
And, obviously, we're
very lucky to be
involved in the production
that we're in right now.
But whether the work that you're
doing is preparing for a role
or it's being perseverant
and getting yourself
up for auditions and, you know,
taking the time when you're not
in a show to work on yourself,
it's all about the process
and not necessarily
the destination.
NICK CARTELL: I
would second that.
Perfect.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: Plus one.
OK.
What is your favorite part of
telling this profound story
every night?
NICK CARTELL: For
me, it's getting
to show the journey of Valjean,
to show how broken a man can be
at the beginning of the show.
All he holds on to is his name
and a single piece of his soul
that's left.
And it's not until the
Bishop forgives him
that that all breaks apart.
And, completely, his entire
world is flipped upside down.
Everything is decimated.
And he has to rebuild
himself from the ground up.
And that by the end of the show,
he's finally found forgiveness
not only for everybody that
he's come in contact with,
but also for himself.
And I think that
telling that story,
there are people that
can connect with that
and that need that
in their lives.
And I think that that for me
is what is the joy for me.
MARY KATE MOORE:
I think the reason
that I said "One Day More"
is my favorite song is
because of how iconic it is.
And so we do it a lot.
We do the show a lot.
We've done it
hundreds of times now.
But--
NICK CARTELL: 331--
SPEAKER 1: Oh, wow. -last
NICK CARTELL: --last night.
MARY KATE MOORE: Oh,
that's the count?
NICK CARTELL: Yeah.
MARY KATE MOORE: OK.
331.
NICK CARTELL: [INAUDIBLE]
MARY KATE MOORE: So that's
a lot of "One Day More."
But if you can really,
like, make yourself
present in that
musical moment, it's
very overwhelming
to be a part of it,
to be marching in
that V formation
and, in the periphery, to
see the red flag waving.
And we're really lucky to be
part of a very talented group
of people.
So there's never a
night when that moment
isn't like breathtaking
even being a part of it.
So that's probably my favorite
theatrical moment of the show.
NICK CARTELL: And I
think that that's also
so cool about this production
of "Les Mis" is that we
have such an amazing cast.
It's a young cast.
We have an energy that we bring
onstage every single night.
But the other thing
that's so amazing
about it is that you can
look at any single person
at any point in the
show and somebody
has something going on.
They're invested.
They are creating
their own stories.
That's what I love
about this company is
that we all support each other.
But, also, we all have
our own ideas and things
happening each night.
MARY KATE MOORE: Yeah.
Everyone's taken a lot of
responsibility for their roles.
And I mean, it's really great
to be a principal performer,
but this show, like the engine
of the show, is the ensemble.
And they're always onstage.
And they are always
committed, and they're really
fun to watch.
So if you go to the
show, make a point
to check out what's happening
behind the immediate action,
because there's always a lot.
NICK CARTELL: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: And
then so what would
you say is the most
challenging part of the show?
MARY KATE MOORE: I have to
experience a lot of emotion
in a very short amount of time.
And it's definitely the kind of
thing that I've gotten used to.
But there are some nights when
just it's not really there.
And so I would say
that's probably
most challenging for me
is finding consistency
with that, because it is such a
tragic story, Fantine's story.
And I am not a very tragic
person in life in general.
So that is difficult,
but very fulfilling.
Yeah.
NICK CARTELL: For me,
I'd say just the stamina.
To do a three hour musical
every single night is a lot.
It's hard.
And it's making sure
you get enough rest
and making sure that
you're warmed up
and, You know, on those days
where you're not feeling great,
figuring out how to
still push through
it and give the audience 100%.
SPEAKER 1: And you
guys are covering
a lot of cities in your tour.
Do you find that
different audiences
have different responses
or anything different
when you go to a new city?
NICK CARTELL: Yeah.
MARY KATE MOORE: Yeah.
We just spent some time
in Canada, actually.
And their theater etiquette
is just different than ours.
So we had a lot of quiet,
but still very appreciative
audiences, which is not
something that we're used to.
You know, we feel kind
of like rock stars
at certain moments of the show,
because the audience is just,
like, going crazy.
NICK CARTELL: Usually,
the overture starts.
And all of a sudden--
MARY KATE MOORE: Yeah.
NICK CARTELL: --there's
this yell from the crowd
and everybody on stage
is like, all right let's
go, let's do it.
MARY KATE MOORE: Yeah.
Yeah.
So you just have to kind of
get used to different energies
from the audiences.
But we've never been
to a city where they
haven't loved what we're doing.
NICK CARTELL: And
leapt to their feet
right at the end of the show.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE] standing up.
MARY KATE MOORE: Oh, yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Switching
gears a little bit more,
have you had any onstage
or backstage mishaps?
And if so, how did you adapt?
NICK CARTELL: I have.
So there's a moment
on the barricade
where I have to let Javert go.
But I still have to
pretend to shoot him.
So I have a rifle, because we
do use live ammunition that's
blanks.
And so I let him go.
I hold the gun for a moment.
I point it up to
the air, and I fire.
And the minute that I
pulled it up into the air,
somehow the strap
that was on the gun
got between the
firing mechanism.
So when I went to
fire, nothing happened.
Because it got stuck.
And there's a prop-- our prop
master, Kurt, is standing off
in the wings.
And he has another gun ready
to go in case that happens.
And I was up in this position.
He heard it.
He went to get his gun.
And right at that moment,
I lowered my gun back
into the wing, and he shot.
[LAUGHTER]
So Valjean is a horrible sight.
Because I didn't actually
kill Javert that night.
That was probably--
yeah, for me,
that was the worst stage mishap
that has happened so far.
Knock on wood.
MARY KATE MOORE:
Yeah, we'll see.
Before I took over the role,
when I was still understudying,
it was the first time
that I ever went on.
So I was feeling very anxious
and excited in Nashville,
actually, Nick's favorite city.
And something happened.
Oh, it was a Life Alert
went off in the house.
I think somebody
with a Life Alert
had come to the show
the night before,
but left the alarm on accident.
So they were like at
their house trying
to find their Life Alarm.
And they, like, kept pressing,
like, find my Life Alert.
And it was just like
going off in the audience.
So I made the entrance
into the factory.
I was so, like,
overstimulated by what
was happening to me
as my principal debut
that I didn't notice
it was happening.
But everybody in the ensemble
was making real weird faces
at me, like, what is going on.
And so at the end of the factory
scene, when Fantine gets thrown
out of the factory,
she ends up upstage
sitting on the ground ready
to go for "I Dreamed a Dream."
So this entire time, I've
been, like, psyching myself up
for the big song.
And I get to my spot, and
the spotlight hits me.
And I hear our stage manager's
voice over the loudspeaker
to the whole
audience, like, we're
going to hold the show,
ladies and gentlemen,
like, as I'm going--
I--
[LAUGHTER]
And so I had to get up and
walk off stage and stand there.
It was just the weirdest
break in like momentum.
So they brought
the curtains down.
And I just kind of stood
there for 2 minutes
like trying to figure
out how to keep it going.
I didn't you know.
I mean-- so then I had what we
call my Tony performance now
where I like went back
out and sat myself down
once they figured it out.
And like, the curtain
rose and the song started.
And then I got to do it.
But that was probably the
biggest one and very memorable.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
I would say so.
NICK CARTELL: There was
also one on the first--
one of our-- on like
our opening night
in Providence, Rhode Island.
MARY KATE MOORE: Oh, yeah.
NICK CARTELL: We got to
the very end of the show.
I mean, literally,
we're in the last song.
And we here, help,
stop, doctor, please!
Somebody had been
crying so hard,
but still decided it was a
good idea to eat peanut M&Ms.
And they literally put one
in their mouth were sobbing,
sucked in, and started choking.
[LAUGHTER]
So we had to stop the show.
We're within the moments
of end of the show.
We had to stop the show.
And then we all had to
file back on, but yeah.
MARY KATE MOORE: Yeah.
NICK CARTELL: There aren't that
many-- we have a great crew.
We have a great group of
people that there aren't
that many mishaps that happen.
MARY KATE MOORE: No, and those
weren't our fault either.
NICK CARTELL: Yeah, those
weren't our fault. Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: You guys
[INAUDIBLE] great.
NICK CARTELL: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: And then along those
lines, too, so for the songs
you're not in, like when you're
backstage, like how do you
stay in character?
Are you just hanging out here?
MARY KATE MOORE: As
soon as I pass away,
I can kind of let go of
Fantine for a little while.
She does come back at
the end of the show.
So I don't really have to
worry about that so much.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
I don't know about you.
NICK CARTELL: Most
of the time I'm not
on stage I'm changing
costume or doing makeup--
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
NICK CARTELL: --or doing
something like that.
So there's always an element
of keeping that there.
But, also, we've done
331 performances of it.
So I figured out how
to get back into it,
take that moment before,
so I can walk back on stage
and sing "Bring Him Home."
SPEAKER 1: So we do have
some questions on the Dory.
I do want to open it
up to the audience.
If anyone has an
audience question,
if you want to come out to this
mic, we can form a little line.
AUDIENCE: So I'm
curious what songs
you chose to sing for your
auditions for these roles
and why you chose them.
NICK CARTELL: Oh.
MARY KATE MOORE: Wow.
You know, for the
first initial audition,
I sang "Memory" from "Cats."
So there's that.
And then from that
point on, they give you
material from the show to sing.
NICK CARTELL: And when I
went in for my audition,
I was just given
material from the show.
So I had to sing "The
Soliloquy," "Bring Him
Home," and "Who Am I?"
And then I also had to
prepare "The Confrontation"
for my final callback.
AUDIENCE: So you
mentioned the cast
doing things in the background.
And we actually got
to see you last night.
And it was excellent.
NICK CARTELL: Amazing.
AUDIENCE: And there were
a lot of really fun bits.
What is your favorite, like,
just a little one second bit
that people do in the show?
MARY KATE MOORE:
Well, I mean, I'm
kind of in a special
position with that,
because I got to be in
the ensemble for a while.
And I think my favorite
scene was always
the Paris scene when you're
first introduced to Eponine.
And you see the
Thenardier's again
after they've sung "Master
of the House" at the end.
There's just so much
going on in that scene.
And what's cool about it is
that every ensemble member
has kind of been given
a different costume
and a different character.
And people get real
serious about it.
So, like, there is true
commitment happening back there
from a lot of them.
So that one's really fun.
NICK CARTELL: I like coming
into the factory, because there
is that level of power that
you walk into as the mayor.
And so to come into the factory
and, you know, say my piece,
and then as I walk up, I
always have the men's ensemble
that come rushing up to
me asking me questions.
And yesterday, was my birthday.
And so--
SPEAKER 1: Yes.
Happy Belated Birthday to Nick.
It was his birthday yesterday.
[APPLAUSE]
NICK CARTELL: Thank you.
Thank you.
But I went walking up the stairs
of the factory at the matinee,
and they all came
rushing up to me.
And I was like, what?
And they all started singing
"Happy Birthday" to me.
[LAUGHTER]
And I was, like, thank you.
You get back to work, you know?
So that was great.
That was great.
SPEAKER 1: That's awesome.
Introduce yourself.
AUDIENCE: My name is Josh.
Thank you for coming.
NICK CARTELL: And Josh--
AUDIENCE: Thanks for
coming here today.
NICK CARTELL: Josh is actually--
AUDIENCE: My question was--
[LAUGHTER]
NICK CARTELL: Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: --specifically
for Mr. Cartell.
NICK CARTELL: Oh.
AUDIENCE: Because it's
such a very serious role.
NICK CARTELL: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And you have
to do it for a long time.
Is there any time that you've
ever broken, like, on stage,
like laughed or anything?
NICK CARTELL: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I'm going to sit down.
SPEAKER 1: Should we
explain who Josh is?
NICK CARTELL: So
that's Josh Davis.
Josh is our Javert in the show.
SPEAKER 1: Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
NICK CARTELL: And
the answer is never.
[LAUGHTER]
Never.
MARY KATE MOORE: Can I talk--
I'm going to talk about that.
NICK CARTELL: Yeah, you can
talk about that, because there
are moments where--
MARY KATE MOORE: So Nick
is such a happy guy.
NICK CARTELL: I am.
MARY KATE MOORE: He is.
And as soon as he starts
smiling, he can't stop.
So I-- I mean, the
most tragic and emotion
filled moment of the show for
me is at the end of the docks
when, like, they're
about to take me to jail.
I don't know what Josh does
when he comes on stage,
but he did something one day
to make Nick start laughing.
And--
NICK CARTELL: Sometimes we'll
just look at each other and--
MARY KATE MOORE: And
that's all it takes.
NICK CARTELL: --if we're in
a mood, then it just happens.
But the thing that
I will say is that
what always pulls me back, like,
if ever I get to that point,
especially when we're
in that dock scene--
MARY KATE MOORE: Yeah.
NICK CARTELL: --she
actually spits on me.
And she will--
MARY KATE MOORE: Yeah.
NICK CARTELL: She
will spit in my face.
And it immediately pulls me in.
MARY KATE MOORE: It's
like training a dog.
NICK CARTELL: It's, like,
all right, here we go.
[LAUGHTER]
MARY KATE MOORE: Yeah.
But it's really
difficult, you know,
when you're trying to cry.
NICK CARTELL: I know.
MARY KATE MOORE:
And he turns around
with a full grin on his face
and sings the line to you.
NICK CARTELL: Never again.
MARY KATE MOORE: Oh, OK.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Do you ever experience
bleed with your character's
emotions coming through and sort
of you feeling the character's
emotions?
Or is it just all
simulated, and you've
done it enough that
that doesn't happen?
MARY KATE MOORE:
Well, the last--
like the last month,
my grandma passed away.
And I thought it was fine.
I thought I was totally fine.
And I didn't really
cry about it,
but I always cry in the show.
And the night right
after it happened,
I wasn't sure after I
got out there and started
crying if I was going to
be able to make it through.
So there are definitely
moments where,
if something's happening for
you in your personal life that
has affected you
emotionally in any way,
this show can be
very therapeutic
for that sort of thing.
But I mean, there's
a very fine line
that you can't
really cross over.
So, yeah, I mean, sometimes
it's really difficult
to meet that line
and not exceed it.
And I'm not sure if--
NICK CARTELL: Yeah, no.
I will totally second that.
Especially if you're
angry about something,
you know, there
are those moments.
For me, my mom passed away the
day before my final callback
for this show.
And so to sing "Bring Him
Home" every night is emotional.
To sing the end of
the show is emotional.
And it is.
It's incredibly therapeutic
to do this show.
And I think it's been
some of the best therapy
in order to do the show.
Because there are moments
where you can cry,
and you can let that
emotion out that sometimes
you might not be able to
do outside of the theater.
MARY KATE MOORE:
It also teaches you
how to access those
emotions though, too.
So, you know, there are
those few performances
where it's dangerous.
But then once you
get past that point,
you can remember what it
feels like to have your chest
constrict like that.
And, you know, the more often
it happens, the more easy
it is to find it, so.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you
for sharing that.
MARY KATE MOORE: Yeah.
NICK CARTELL: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If you could play
another character in "Les
Mis" for one night, would you?
And who would it be?
NICK CARTELL: Oh.
MARY KATE MOORE: Am
I going for first?
NICK CARTELL: Yes.
MARY KATE MOORE: Well, I've
always wanted to be a bass,
so probably Javert.
NICK CARTELL: And I would say I
would like to play Javert, too.
MARY KATE MOORE: Oh.
Watch out, Josh.
NICK CARTELL: I'd like to
play the other side of it.
SPEAKER 1: Coming for you.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So I am someone who
inspires to be in the arts.
And I'm curious, because
there's a lot of trial and error
in starting a career.
Is there something
you're really glad you
did when you first started
really putting yourself out
there?
And is there
something you kind of
wish you'd done differently,
maybe not as much energy into
or, oh, you know don't worry
about that, just do this?
What is your advice in that?
Like, something
you're super glad you
did at the start of your
career and something
you wish you'd maybe
done differently?
NICK CARTELL: I
wish that I would
have gotten into
more dance for me,
especially in musical theater.
I can move, but
I'm not a dancer.
And I wish that I could do it.
I wish I could tap dance more.
I wish I could, you know,
do all those things.
I don't think that
there was anything
that I would say I'm sorry
that I put my energy into.
Because I feel like
everything that I
did in some way, shape, or
form was a learning experience.
It was a way to figure
out, all right, this
is the right thing to do or
this is the wrong thing to do.
So that's me.
MARY KATE MOORE: Yeah.
I think it's--
I mean, that's a
really good question,
but there's no formula
for success in my opinion.
So anything that
you might experience
as an aspiring performer was
meant for you to experience.
So I would just say that
it's important for you
to have patience and
to be kind to yourself,
because there are probably a
lot of people in the world who
won't be that nice to you.
But there are a lot
of people who will be
incredible and super helpful.
And, yeah, just look for
the lesson in everything,
because it's always there.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious.
As you're seeing, like, in
a forum like this or even
on stage, like, are you looking
at the audience in their eyes,
like directly
making eye contact?
Or, especially as you're in
this big emotional journey
where the audience
may or may not
be, like, feeling
it quite the same,
is it awkward to be looking
at someone who is just sort
of like looking up at you?
Or do you kind of focus more
generally in the theater?
MARY KATE MOORE: In
some houses, that's
impossible to be able to
make eye contact with people
just because of how dark it
is or how far away they are.
But, like, here in Denver,
we're close to the first, like,
maybe 15 rows.
So I can see facial features.
And I find it helpful,
because so much of this show
is a lesson, you know?
So many of the songs that
you're singing, so many
of the arguments or
conversations that you have
with people through song
are about this struggle
of the human spirit and
things that we've all
experienced before.
So I'm not afraid to make
eye contact with people.
NICK CARTELL: Yeah.
And at the beginning of
the show especially, you
know, I kind of break
the fourth wall a bit.
And I am singing
to the audience.
And I'm yelling at the audience.
And to be able to have
those people that you can--
and they're, like, oh, OK.
[LAUGHTER]
He's looking at me now?
Why?
And it is.
It's because we have
a lesson to tell,
and we have a story that
we're trying to get across.
And if we can connect
with people on that level,
then it just makes
it better for us.
And I feel like it makes it--
MARY KATE MOORE: Oh, yeah.
NICK CARTELL: -- a more riching
experience for the audience.
MARY KATE MOORE: It's always--
it's a goal of a
performer, I think,
to make the audience
feel like they
are part of what's happening,
because that's really
kind of how the
lessons stick I think.
So, yeah.
NICK CARTELL: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: You said
you've done 331 shows.
What has been, like, the
most memorable moment?
NICK CARTELL: For me, the
most memorable moment--
and it wasn't in a show.
It was actually when we
were still in rehearsal.
And it was we were going
into our day of sitzprobe.
And the sitzprobe is it's the
first time that the actors are
singing with an orchestra.
So we are all on stage.
And we are walking up to
just stand microphones,
and we're singing with
this beautiful orchestra.
And sitting in front of us
is Claude-Michel Schonberg
and Alain Boublil,
who wrote the show.
SPEAKER 1: Wow.
NICK CARTELL: And to
have that experience
of singing their music
for them, it is a moment
that I will never forget.
MARY KATE MOORE: Yeah,
that's a big one.
I would say mine's probably
in that same time period
when we were in
previews in Providence.
And the entire creative
team of Les Miserables
came to see us do that.
And we had all, you know,
heard the reputation
that Cameron Mackintosh has.
He's a very particular man and
knows exactly what he likes.
And when he came into
our note session,
the day after he
saw our show, he
didn't have anything negative
to say about us as an ensemble.
And so that was very cool.
I mean, we were all
excited about that.
But then soon as he left,
our Associate Director
was, like, I just want you
guys to know that I've never
heard him say that before.
SPEAKER 1: Wow.
MARY KATE MOORE: So
knowing that and knowing
how strong of a group of
performers we are, you know,
it gives you a lot of pride
for the work that you do.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, that's
a huge compliment.
MARY KATE MOORE: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: --from
Cameron Mackintosh.
And then so I'm assuming
you're not always
listening to "Les Mis"
when you're not in a show.
Is there any other, you
know, current musical cast
recordings you're
listening to or any songs
you listen to to, like, get
pumped up before the show?
MARY KATE MOORE: I'm a bad
musical theater person.
I don't, like, really
listen to cast recordings
unless I need to for a show.
So I guess, I mean,
I've been listening
to a lot of Fleetwood Mac in
the dressing rooms lately.
SPEAKER 1: That's great.
MARY KATE MOORE: So
[INAUDIBLE] that.
NICK CARTELL: I just
kind of put on Spotify.
MARY KATE MOORE: Yeah.
NICK CARTELL: And just
how the mood hits me,
sometimes it's jazz.
Sometimes it's big band.
Sometimes it's, you know.
Whatever I need to pump me
up in order to do the show
or whatever mood
I'm in, that's kind
of what pushes me in
the right direction.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering if
you happened to find yourself,
you know, in the midst
of a group of people who
are involved in technology--
[LAUGHTER]
--what sort of
technology improvements
would help people
in musical theater?
NICK CARTELL: Oh.
MARY KATE MOORE: Oh.
SPEAKER 1: Very good question.
MARY KATE MOORE: Oh my gosh.
[LAUGHTER]
We're kind of set.
I mean, I feel good about--
NICK CARTELL: I think something
that would be amazing--
and I know the technology
is sort of there,
but I don't think it's been,
you know, immediately or--
I don't know how to say that.
But when we get
into every city, we
have a local crew that
we pick up in every city.
So we travel with a crew
of about 20 to 25 people.
And then we pick up maybe
about another 50 to 75 people
to help us do the
show every night.
And sometimes-- well,
a lot of the time
it's the spotlights
that are on somebody.
Like, it's a local
person and they're
having to say, all right,
you need to be on Valjean.
You need to be on
Valjean right now.
And the spotlight will come
up over there, and I'm here.
So if there was technology
that you could wear something
on your costume that they
could just put up the light
and it would be on
you as a spotlight,
I think that would be amazing.
MARY KATE MOORE: Yeah.
That would be super cool.
I'm technologically
challenged, so maybe just
like somebody helping me.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: I think we
can find someone here.
MARY KATE MOORE: OK, great.
Awesome.
Come talk to me after.
Yeah, thank you.
That was a good question.
I had to think about that.
SPEAKER 1: So thank you
both so much for being here.
And, yeah, thank you.
[INAUDIBLE] give them
around of applause.
NICK CARTELL: Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
[APPLAUSE]